what's all this about tonight
do you ever think about what the liberal
Society requires
you have to study some old things to
know
first of all it was unknown in the
ancient world
in the ancient world the rule was
if the law does not permit a thing it
commands a thing
in the modern world the rule is if the
law does not forbid a thing
the thing is permissible
liberal Society to free Society it
happens
in that unstated area
and everything depends upon how big it
is
there have to be laws in any kind of
society
and the people who make the laws the
institutions that make the laws they
have to have a monopoly on Force
because
you can't have the bandits outgun in the
sheriff
and so that means that the people who
live the private lives
in the liberal free un uh
private discretion part of the world
somehow they have to have a way to
control this thing that has a monopoly
on Force
the greatest instrument for doing that
in history is the Constitution the
United States
and it is disappearing
it means that we live in a time when we
may see despotism we are seeing death
Buddhism Among Us
we see people carrying guns
using the force to which they are
entrusted
for partisan purposes their own partisan
purposes
what are we going to do about that
this greatest experiment
inequality and Liberty
it's in Peril right now as if it were
1850.
our speaker
understands all that
I had known him a while and I've
followed him a while this book
because we do charter schools in Florida
and we do them several States
and not meaning any invidious
distinctions
Florida is the best
they they know what they're doing you
know they
work with them
they keep their word they make things
happen
they're not backbiting one another all
the time
and I finally noticed that and you know
you don't expect expect that from
government these days
and I began to pay more attention to
Florida
and then I found our speaker tonight
I began to notice him
he's written a book that shows
how much he understands the first
paragraph of the book
begins with the discussion of one of my
oldest friends the very recently
deceased Angelo codavillaum I met the
first time in 1974.
who brought into current Politics the
expression the ruling class
because that's what it is
you know there's a fair number of
prosperous people in this room
and they're not members of the ruling
class
and the reason is they don't want to
rule anybody except by their consent
the ruling class does want to do that
and is doing that increasingly
well
I never met anybody
uh
who at this stage in a political career
has thought that through and has a plan
about it
and so I think he's a very important man
and I'm proud to present to you Ron
DeSantis
thank you
thank you so much
thank you Dr Arn it's it's great to be
at Hillsdale it's great to be in
Michigan you know as the governor of the
Free State of Florida when I want to
visit michiganders in early April I
usually just go to Naples because
I think the entire Midwest is down in
Southwest Florida
but we are proud to be here waving the
flag for the free estate in these United
States and it's not something that came
by accident it's something that took a
lot of work a lot of effort and we talk
about it a little bit in the book in
2018 so four and a half years ago I was
elected by 32 000 votes out of over 8
million votes that were cast in the
State of Florida it was less than one
half of one percent and if you look the
previous decade in the State of Florida
before me becoming governor
we had one point races Governor
president 2010 12 14 16 18 one point and
all those Marquee races and so when I
was getting ready to take office a lot
of people told me and not unreasonably
uh trim your sales Don't Rock the Boat
closely divided State very close
election uh just uh kind of keep your
head down don't make any waves because
you don't want to upset this political
balance in the State of Florida in a way
that's not going to redown to your
benefit and I understood that advice but
I also rejected that advice my view
my view as I may have earned a mere 50
percent of the vote but that entitled me
to wield 100 percent of the executive
power and I intended to do that uh to
advance our agenda and to deliver for
the people of Florida now as you're
preparing to do that before we took
office I was mindful that being elected
the chief executive of a state is not
the same as being elected for the
dictator of the state as much as the
media tries to act like we we do that
the reality is we've been able to be
effective at wielding this power because
I had an understanding of where the
pressure points are what the limits were
I had all my staff compile all the list
of all the Constitutional statutory and
customary powers of the government of
the governor I had an agenda that I
needed to get through a constitutional
system that had checks and balances and
separation of powers so we had a good
sense of where the pressure points were
we knew how we could use our executive
leverage I knew what my Powers were
vis-a-vis local government I've removed
people like Sheriff of Broward after
Parkland I removed supervisors of
Elections I have removed a George Soros
funded prosecutor in Tampa
so we we knew that not only did we have
to deliver substantively but in order to
deliver substantively we had to navigate
uh that constitutional system and we had
a plan to do it and we executed I also
said uh I'm not taking polls as Governor
uh Florida uh I can take a poll of this
room and first of all I can take a poll
this room ask the question a different
way and get a different result because
it's dependent on the wording but oppose
a static analysis of what people may
think at a given time what a poll
doesn't tell you is what the result
would be if a leader sets out a vision
executes on that vision and then
delivers results because if you do that
you can move people in your direction so
a leader is not captive to polls not
responsive or or responsive to every
blip in public opinion leader gets ahead
of those things a leader drives public
opinion and so that's what we set out to
do and that's what we ended up doing I
also said that I could be the best
decision maker I could have a great
vision I could do all this or any
Governor could do all that but if you
don't have people serving in the
administration who share the vision and
are going to be on the ground
implementing that Vision then it's not
going to amount to very much and the
reality is in politics you have people
that can be drawn that are bringing
their own agenda to what is going on and
I made it very clear if you have any
other agenda but what the best interests
of the State of Florida is and the best
interests of our agenda if you have any
other agenda pack your bags and leave
and we had to dismiss some people early
but the result has been and you know to
hear people like Dr Arn talk about how
Florida gets it done on all this stuff
you know Matt Spalding has worked with
these with our folks they are able to
carry in these ideas and actually get it
to stick we don't do Palace Intrigue we
don't do any drama in fact we don't talk
to the media we had no leaks in the
media for over four years and they get
very upset about that the way we speak
is through our actions you never know
what's going to happen the next day you
never know what announcement we're going
to roll out you never know uh what lever
we're going to pull but that's how we
make news by doing substantive things
and I think that that served us well
finally I said I am not going to be like
some of these Republicans that get into
office and they're like potted plants
they don't do anything they play defense
all the time
no
we're going on offense in the State of
Florida and so we did go on offense we
were very aggressive I mean really for
all the four years of my first term on
always leaning into issues first of all
that's the better way to do it energy
and the executive Alexander Hamilton
said is the leading characteristic of
good governance we are able to shape the
agenda particularly in a big state as
being the chief executive but it's also
a great form of Defense because if
you're not doing anything offensively
then the left in the media just starts
shooting at you all the time and yeah
they still shoot at me but they always
miss the Target because the minute they
start complaining about one thing I'm
off doing the next thing so the best
defense is a good offense and that's
what we did
so we set out with kind of that frame of
mind and before we fast forward four
years later whereas we had initially
been elected by 32 000 votes we were
re-elected by over 1.5 million votes we
earn
we earned the highest percentage of the
vote that any Republican governor
candidate has ever received in the
history of the State of Florida we were
able to win 62 of 67 counties including
places like Palm Beach County and we won
Miami-Dade County by double digits which
nobody thought was possible we also
helped Usher and super majorities in the
Florida legislature we have the largest
legislative majority in the modern
history of Florida we were able to elect
29 conservative school board members
throughout the State of Florida and we
flip school boards
and for the first time since the Civil
War period there's not a single Democrat
elected to Statewide office in the
entire state of Florida
[Applause]
and we did that which is great and I
could say you know we won by 1.58 but
you know what are you doing to have a
lasting durable Legacy in terms of the
political Legacy and what we are able to
do is not just win a victory that will
disappear in upcoming elections we
basically realign the state from a swing
state the nation's biggest most
expensive most important swing state
into a red State when I became Governor
we had almost 300 000 more registered
Democrats than Republicans in the State
of Florida and we had never in the
history of Florida had more registered
Republicans and Democrats well fast
forward to today we not only do we have
more Republicans and Democrats we have
000 more Republicans and Democrats
that's a 700 000 plus registration swing
so that's durable and that's meaningful
and we only did it because people
responded uh to to our leadership and so
when we talk about the free state of
Florida yes I mean freedom in a sense of
absence of government getting involved
in your business I think that's
typically when you believe in
constitutionally limited government you
keep government in its Corner keep it
cabin and I think traditionally we
assume the rest of society would
function uh better well I think modern
times we've seen the left get into so
many different arteries of our society
so yes you have to limit government's
involvement with you but you also have
to contest the left and all these other
institutions so when I say the free
state of Florida I mean not only limited
government but I also mean I have a
responsibility to protect my citizens
from having the pathologies of the left
imposed upon them by all these other
institutions in our society so yes we
win legislative battles the State of
Florida has no income tax you guys in
Michigan should try that sometime it
works out pretty good
we have our budget in Florida even
though we have millions of more people
than the state of New York our budget is
half the size of the budget of the state
of New York yeah we have better Services
education and infrastructure where is
their money going uh so we have one of
the smallest per capita tax and debt and
government employee ratios anywhere in
the country that's traditional limited
government good for business good for
economic growth absolutely but that in
this day and age is not enough and there
are some Republicans that think their
job is to cut taxes and not do anything
else that is not how we conceive of our
job we in Florida drove the stake in the
heart of covid authoritarianism in this
country
we saved the country from falchism
and if you remember back particularly in
some of the early weeks and months no
Governor took more incoming fire from
Legacy Media from the left from
bureaucrats Heck from The White House
and even from many other Republicans
than me and a lot of my supporters were
telling me man you are absolutely
blowing this people are attacking you
you got to do something different but
you know I had studied the the data I
had studied the Medical Science I had
consulted with actual experts unlike
people like fauci
and I was convinced that you had to keep
Society going you had to have kids in
school you had to have all that but we
were criticized relentlessly but I made
the decision that when you're the
executive you have to put the jobs of
the people you represent ahead of your
own job and I didn't know what was going
to happen politically for me but I was
willing to let the chips fall where they
may and so we stood our ground and
really the rest is history not only did
we lead on all those issues we have
enacted protections for Floridians
against covid shot mandates for school
children against vaccine passports and
against uh job mandates so people don't
lose their job over a kova job we're
proud of that
what that showed you the fact that they
still to this day want to keep Djokovic
out of the United States from playing
tennis because he didn't take an mnra
shot the fact that they're in federal
court on appeal trying to overturn a
judge in Florida who did a great ruling
to strike down the airline mask mandate
they want that reimposed incredibly what
that shows you is all this medical stuff
was not about your health it was about
them exercising control over your
behavior that was what they wanted to do
and they will try to do it again we also
are protecting people from the less
delusional views of Criminal Justice and
lack of Law and Order and you're seeing
this in places all throughout this
country where they tried to defund
police where you had riots when we saw
the riots in Minneapolis and started
seeing it spread to New York City since
places I mobilized the National Guard in
Florida I had state law enforcement
station in the urban areas and we said
very clearly you're not burning down our
cities and guess what it didn't happen
because we knew they knew that we would
hold them accountable we also passed
legislation in Florida barring local
governments from defunding the police
they can try to do it we're going to put
the money back in any Community any City
at any given time could elect three
bozos to the city council who would do
stupid things I'm not going to let our
Public Safety suffer as a result of them
going on some ideological Joyride
we are also protecting parents and
students from the left's views on
education and particularly their
attempts to use our school system to
indoctrinate students not just in K-12
but also in higher education we believe
that parents have rights to be involved
in the education and upbringing of their
kids and those are rights that the
government of Florida respects
we believe in banning and we have banned
Concepts like critical race Theory from
being used in our K-12 schools we're not
going to teach our students to hate this
country or to hate each other no we are
actually going to teach kids that they
should be judged as individuals and that
it's their content of their character
that matters not the color of their skin
but we also understand you can say what
you don't want in terms of things like
CRT what are you for we've led the
nation in promoting American Civics and
teaching students what it means to be an
American we don't want to graduate
listless vessels who have no clue about
our country's history or our country's
principles and so in order to do that
we've done a lot with standards and
tests and all this stuff but we created
a program for teachers 50 hours of
instruction we had folks from Hillsdale
Matt Spalding others other people around
the country contribute to this where
they're actually learning all the
intellectual foundations of the Amer
American Republic in a way that I don't
think any other state has done in modern
history and when the teachers go through
that they get a three thousand dollar
bonus for doing so so we are on offense
when it comes to American Civics we've
also identified one day a year November
7th as a date when our students get
instruction on the victims of communist
regimes throughout history we're going
to tell the truth about Marxism and
leninism
We Believe parents have a right to know
what's being taught in the schools and
have access to curriculum and we've
enacted curriculum transparency
legislation the media will some and
here's the thing this wasn't true when I
was in school and I graduated from
public high school in Florida but they
are putting pornographic materials in
the schools why are they doing this it's
an agenda but parents have a right to
send their ten-year-old to school
without them being exposed to this so
we've empowered parents to object when
things violate our standards what the
media says is Florida wants to ban books
they don't want access to books and you
know first of all adults can do what
they want a school by definition has to
curate what's in a library or curate
what's in a classroom and if you're
using tax dollars to make decisions to
put pornographic materials in that's not
an appropriate use of our tax dollars
we're going to make sure that that's not
happening I did an event to expose this
we called it exposing the book ban hoax
but before I brought the parents up to
talk before I said anything we played a
video where we showed all this material
that the parents had been objecting to
the local news crews covering it had to
cut their feed they said it was too
graphic to show
well if it's too graphic for the six
o'clock news how is it appropriate for a
nine-year-old kid
we've also drawn A Line in the Sand and
said that parents in Florida have a
right to send their kids to school
without having a teacher telling their
kids that they can change their gender
or that they can pick different pronouns
uh gender ideology should not be taught
in our K-12 schools and I don't care if
Disney feels otherwise we're going to
make sure we're standing with parents
and we're standing with students
we're also leaning in on higher
education I mean it's sad that you know
you have conservative parents throughout
the country asking you know where can I
send my kid and yes people will say
Hillsdale they may say a few others but
the list ain't that long and uh and
that's because higher education has gone
from traditional understanding of
pursuing truth and and providing people
with a foundation so that they can think
for themselves and be citizens of our
Republic to imposing ideology uh
political activism quote social justice
and so in Florida we said no you know
those are not appropriate we want to
read more our institutions back to the
traditional classical Mission and so
we've done things like now in Florida
all the tenured professors have to
undergo review every five years and the
bad ones can be let go so you're going
to be able to clear out a lot of
underbrush in our universities
we also are I'll be signing legislation
within the next couple weeks to
eliminate all so-called Dei programs
from the state of Florida's universities
they say it's diversity Equity inclusion
but in reality those are euphemisms it's
really ideology imposed through the
administrative apparatus of the
University uh and I think it's Dei is
division exclusion and indoctrination
and that has no place in our public
institutions
and they mentioned uh people have
mentioned we put six conservative board
members on a small liberal arts college
in Sarasota called new College I put Dr
Spaulding on I put Christopher rufo from
The Manhattan Institute and some other
people they came in got rid of the
president hired a conservative president
eliminated Dei and CRT president fired
the Provost and it's now been a new
mission of being a classical liberal
arts college so we're going to be like a
little Hillsdale maybe a dead down in
Florida can you imagine how good that
would be
we also protect our citizens against the
wages of the Biden border crisis and
when I became Governor a lot of people
said in Florida you can't be strong on
immigration because Republicans rely on
Hispanic voters well I was Stronger on
immigration than any governor in history
and I won the highest percentage of
Latino voters in 2022 of anybody in
history so that that's not true so we've
done things like bands Sanctuary cities
in the state of Florida we sued Biden
and won and we may end up uh eliminating
his catch and release program as a
result we are not a border state in
terms of the Southern border but we're a
maritime State and we have boats coming
in from Haiti and all these other places
trying to dump people in Florida so I've
done we're under a state of emergency I
have Florida Maritime assets working
with the Coast Guard and since August
we've been able to interdict and
repatriate over 11 000 illegal aliens
send back to Haiti send back to Cuba
making sure that we're enforcing the
rule of law very important
we all you know here's the thing you
have fentanyl coming across the border
overdoses are spiking all across the
United States you do have criminal
aliens coming across you have people
that DHS says not me DHS says is on the
terrorist watch list we know we have
people from China that have come across
the southern border so this affects
communities everywhere and yet our
Legacy Media
doesn't really care about that they
don't care about the fentanyl overdoses
they don't care about the criminal
layers they don't care about the
lawlessness they only seem to care when
50 illegal aliens showed up at beautiful
Martha's Vineyard then they got really
upset about that
because it was puncturing their little
cocoon and this was a very wealthy
Enclave that had advertised itself as
being a sanctuary City even though these
border towns are getting overrun they
advertise 50 was too much for them to
bear so they called out the National
Guard and deported them within 24 hours
so these are people these these leftists
Elites they want to impose their Vision
on society but they don't want to have
to suffer the consequences of that
Vision they want you to suffer the
consequences they want all of us to
suffer and so I think we really expose
that with that issue but it needs to be
taken care of so in Florida we're
leaning in on it we're going to continue
to do that and I think our state is
safer as a result we're also working to
protect our people against an
increasingly weaponized Federal
apparatus and if you remember what did
Biden do in 2021 after all of 2020
saying ever everyone's saying these
nurses were Heroes cops were Heroes
firefighters were Heroes for responding
to covid what did they want to do in
2021 they wanted all those people to
lose their job if they did not take an
mRNA shot
and so in Florida uh you know we said no
uh we called a special session of the
Florida legislature to enact protections
so that no Floridian has to choose
between a job they need and a shot they
don't want when CMS mandate was
incredibly upheld by the Supreme Court
we made the decision that we were not
going to cooperate with the federal
government on implementing that they
find me two million dollars but you know
what I saved tens of thousands of jobs
for nurses so I'm happy to do it and we
told the federal government to pound
sand
[Applause]
but what
but what kind of apparatus is this
Congress never legislated whether they
could legislate a vax mandate I don't
think they probably could uh but put
that aside Congress never did anything
on this they just took the
administrative State and they used it
they weaponized it to try to deny people
Americans the right to put food on their
table if they didn't bend the knee over
the jab that is unacceptable we are also
working to prevent agencies in the State
of Florida from working with any any
federal agency that is colluding with
big tech companies to censor information
from Americans they did it during covid
they did it during the 2020 election how
that was allowed to go on is beyond me
but I'll tell you none of our state or
local agencies are allowed to
participate in that either directly with
tech or working with federal agencies
that are doing the same that is
weaponizing federal power that is
subcontracting out things you could not
do directly to tech companies to do
indirectly and that is wrong and just
think about what we've seen with the FBI
mobilizing agents to go after mothers
going to school board meetings in
Virginia yeah yeah they had to pull back
on that because there was so much
outrage but how could we possibly have a
situation where that would be something
that would be viewed as acceptable you
know they should be working on who's
coming across the border they should be
working on doing things that really
matter they should not be working
worrying about school board meetings and
yet they were so our freedom in Florida
I would say is full spectrum it requires
us to be very Vigilant it requires us to
lean in on issues that are not always
comfortable for Republicans when you
start talking about taking on woke
capital and big corporate corporations
things like ESG we which we've
eliminated from our pension fund woke
banking which were
protecting people from
you know these are these are Big deals
uh and it's and it's important but we
have to stand up you can't have a
society in which someone like me can win
by 1.5 million votes decimate the left
electorally for maybe a generation and
then have the left impose their agenda
through all these other institutions
that doesn't work so our task in Florida
uh is to carry what George Washington
called the torch of the Sacred fire of
Liberty now this was a torch that burned
in Philadelphia in 1776 when 56 men
pledged their lives their fortune and
their sacred honor to establish a new
nation conceived in Liberty it was a
torch a fire that burned at a cemetery
in Gettysburg when the first Republican
president in our country pledged this
nation a new birth of Freedom it's a
fire that burned on the beaches of
Normandy in the shores of France when a
Mary Band of Brothers defeated the Nazi
please and say freedom in the world and
it is a fire that burned at the steps of
the Berlin wall when a great president
stood up to Communism and said Mr
Gorbachev tear down this wall so
so it's Fallen the freedom-loving people
throughout our country to carry this
torch it's a responsibility but it's one
in Florida that we welcome uh it's a
responsibility that we believe we have
no other choice but to meet we affirm
the basic Creed of our country that our
rights do not come from government but
they come from the hand of almighty God
we reject the idea
we reject the idea that self-government
can be subcontracted out to bureaucratic
Elites whether borrowed and federal
agencies in Washington D.C or in places
like Davos Switzerland we insist on the
restoration of the Timeless
constitutional principles that have made
this country unique so that government
of by and for the people shall not
perish from this Earth this is not easy
there's no easy course anytime you're
stepping up and leading against the left
you are going to face repercussions and
it's not just a guy like me who's
Governor if you're a parent that's
concerned about what's going on in the
school system you go to a school board
meeting and you speak out you're not
going to be lionized by Legacy Media
you're going to be attacked by Legacy
Media you're not going to be accepted by
the left you're going to be attacked by
the left and so part of the reason we
did the book entitled it the courage to
be free because I think in this day age
when you're fighting the left across a
full spectrum of Institutions you can be
right on the issues you can have the
right frame of mind but you got to have
the courage of your convictions and if
you don't have that then none of this is
going to work and so my message of
freedom from Florida requires us to
stand firm it requires us to hold the
line and it requires us to never ever
back down thank you all God bless thanks
so much
thank you so great to be here God bless
you all
God Bless America thank you
appreciate it
thank you governor
that was a wonderful clear speech but it
was a little vague what
explain a little more what you mean by
bozo
local government I'll tell you it's very
interesting
I I want to talk about your book I urge
you to read the book I
I'm too well educated to enjoy books by
politic politicians
but I like this one
and I was even a little surprised that I
did I admire the governor very much but
um
first of all I'll comment that this book
has a little bit of the atmosphere
of the Peril of the Roman Republic
a chapter that has praetorian guard in
it as a title chapter
uh you talk about
the death of
us running the country instead of in
replaced by a ruling class
explain that a little bit and
why so urgent
sure so first of all I actually did
write the book I mean I know most people
in my position would not and it wasn't
that I I mean I you know basically say
how did you manage to do that your
governor and I was running for
re-election all this stuff and basically
I just slept less I cut that back on the
sleep and you just made it happen late
at night for a period of many months uh
but I did not want to like to have
someone else write it because it
wouldn't have been authentically in my
voice and so I was the only one that
could do it so we did do it I think if
you look I mean what we've really seen
is we've seen and this has happened over
many many years and decades we've seen
constitutional uh government just be
unmoored from the the founding ideals
from the rule of law you see an
administrative state that is
unaccountable partially through the
neglect of Congress by not using the
power of the purse to rein it in
partially because Congress has delegated
lawmaking authority to unelected federal
agencies partially because you haven't
had Executives that have been really
willing to wield article 2 power to root
out some of the problems that we see you
have a media which basically serves this
regime they serve the intelligence
agencies they serve the the entrenched
establishment and the media used to
Pride itself on speaking truth to power
and basically what they do is they
defend the current Arrangements against
anybody who would dine to speak out
against it or or fight against it and so
we really have a situation in which so
much power is being exercised in ways
that are not accountable to the
electorate and I think that power is
being exercised in ways that are
contrary to conservative ideas and I
think that's substantively problematic
but I think even larger is how much more
power is going to be wielded by this
ruling class without effectively the
consent of the government and they are a
minority view in this country uh
regardless of what anyone would like to
tell you so I think think that it is a
crisis of self-government I think we
need a Revival of true American
constitutional principles but you really
need the restoration of accountability
over these agencies and over the
administrative state
thank you thank you
I see that Dean Copeland is in favor of
that
um
you have from uh it's it starts with
your plan of Reform seems to me to dwell
on the Congress first what should
Congress do different well look I mean I
think so I was I was a U.S congressman
for three terms I've recovered from that
experience don't worry
but what happens is is you have a
government that's on autopilot so they
will either do massive Omnibus spending
bills which nobody really reads or has
any idea what's in it or they will do
what's called continuing resolutions
which just keeps the government going uh
whatever the previous year's levels of
Appropriations were the problem with
that is that that they're never using
that number one constitutional power
they have the power of the purse to rein
in these administrative agencies and so
you have something like doj and FBI well
if you never hold them accountable
through the legislative process either
through through law or through through
budget of course power is going to
accumulate there you've also had kind of
a Trope that a lot of Republican
presidents have accepted over the years
that doj and FBI are quote independent
of the White House and first of all
these people have guns they can put in
jail saying they're independent means
they're unaccountable no they are
executive branch agencies that report to
the elected president of the United
States and an executive elected
executive absolutely has to use Article
2 power to hold those agencies
accountable so I think you've had an
executive branch that's not wanted to do
anything to reel them in by holding them
accountable and getting involved in what
they're doing and then I think you've
had a congress which is just totally
given up on using the purse strings and
it's almost like these agencies just
have a right to operate infinitum when
you send that signal over many decades
it's just human nature they are going to
abuse their power I mean the founders
would have predicted that in a New York
minute so I think that a lot of this is
an abdication of Congress if you're
scared of a quote government shutdown
above all else because you're worried
about some bad news Cycles just
understand you're putting that I would
say very small political impulse ahead
of doing your duty to its to ensure that
our apparatus is constitutionally
accountable I'd rather have the fight to
try to discipline the agencies and let
the chips fall where they may then just
allow the status quo to continue in the
direction that it has gone in
uh you're in the Congress for three
terms and you helped to form the freedom
caucus
are you optimistic that that's going to
get better in the Congress
you know I mean there's sometimes I am I
mean I think that that uh the freedom
caucus was based in the you know the DC
hated the freedom caucus I mean K Street
hated it uh Republican leadership ate it
the Press hated it everybody but
basically I think what we were trying to
do is we were identifying what was kind
of the fundamental problem with
republicans in Congress at the time and
the fundamental problem is there was a
massive gap between what we would tell
our constituents we would do what they
wanted to see us do and kind of what the
leadership was doing once everybody got
to Washington and that Gap is just not
the way you govern I mean you have to
represent the people that sent you there
so if you're campaigning on all these
things you got to follow through on on
these things and there just wasn't an
appetite to do it so that's why the
natives and and in my constituents you
know they were like you know thanks for
what you're doing but and they were so
frustrated with a lot of the leadership
and everything so that was just the
reality so the freedom caucus is like
look if we can campaign on it then we
should do it and you'll have these
political Consultants they'll run
campaigns for some of these members of
Congress they get a primary challenge or
something and man they are as
conservative as sliced bread during that
primary and then they get up and then
it's like let's just let the swamp
continue on and so that was that real
disconnect that we were trying to close
uh it was not necessarily terribly
effective then I think they've had some
successes uh recently but you know you
say what you want about the Democrats
what their leadership does is they
represent kind of the Beating Heart of
their left-wing base and Democrat voters
typically have a much higher regard for
Democrat leaders in Congress than our
Republican voters have had of Republican
leaders in Congress and you just you
can't govern effectively uh if you're
basically telling your base uh take a
hike on almost every major issue and
that's just what's happened over a
number of period of years and so the
freedom caucus is like well look all
we're looking at is what you've said you
said you would do we're looking at your
campaigns all right let's do it and they
didn't like that very much
[Applause]
uh
you're an executive now
is that better and why is it better
yeah yes it's better I mean well look
honestly it depends on on your makeup
right because as a member of Congress
you're one of 435. buck that and stop
with you
you can kind of hide in the crowd you
can lay low you can do all that no
scrutiny if that's how you want to do it
and some people would just prefer that
some people like getting involved in
these issues like contributing but they
don't necessarily want to spoil them the
executive you know the buck stops with
you and and you're you're the rod that
people will go after I mean in Florida I
mean anything happens the left will
blame me for it right I mean it doesn't
matter like there could be a crack on
the sidewalk and some some Municipal
DeSantis isn't doing it so so that's
just the nature of it but uh the good
thing is is you know you have the
ability to make the decisions and so I'm
somebody that I'm very thorough on how I
analyze things but it's like you analyze
it you look around you know you get
whatever advice you want to get and then
you pull the trigger and you stick with
it and then you go and I'm very
comfortable doing that I'm very
comfortable leaning into issues and
getting blowback from the Legacy Media
from the left in fact if I do things in
don't get blow back I kind of look in
the mirror and wonder like did I not do
it right or what I mean I I view it as a
as positive feedback basically because I
must be on the right track but it's a
different mindset and it's a different
type of uh of office so if you're
somebody that likes to get in front if
you like to set the agenda if you like
that you know ultimately the buck stops
with you I mean it is a hundred times
better not everybody though necessarily
likes that I mean some you have some
governors in this country they don't
like to make decisions they hope
everything kind of just Fizzles out
before it gets to their desk that's not
me I mean I'm very active I want to be
involved that the legislature is not
moving enough you know I will prod and
push to try to I when I sat down at my
desk my first day in office I looked
around and I said you know I don't know
what SOB is going to succeed me but they
ain't going to have anything to do
because I'm taking all the meat off the
bone I'm gonna make sure I get
everything done and that's just kind of
how I've been our mindset
the reason the Congress is important you
explain in your book is that
they've delegated the legislative
authority to somebody else and
why did they do that and how do you get
them to stop well I think they did it I
mean one reason they did it is just it
insulates them politically from the
decisions that are made if they're
simply inviting an administrative agency
to make determinations on I don't know
something involving fuel or agriculture
all this stuff well then the people that
don't like that they get mad at the
executive agency they may not
necessarily get mad at Congress and so
it probably helps them stay in office
because anytime you you take a hard
stand on something you're gonna you're
gonna alienate somebody so I think part
of it is uh they think it's the easier
path to re-election to let the hard
decisions be made by people who are not
accountable to the electorate and then I
think there has been a view probably
starting in the Progressive Era that you
know government these issues are just
too complex for elected officials so you
need to entrust power and quote experts
to be able to determine what the policy
should be how did that work out during
covid I mean are these people you want
to be entrusting with these decisions so
I think the whole Insight is applaud I
think we live in a representative
government to where we're electing
people to have to make decisions you're
not going to be an expert on anything
but you can bring people in talk with
them figure out what makes sense policy
wise but then it's really up to Congress
to enact the desired policy not just to
legislate suggestions or open
invitations to administrative agencies
that have a lot of power to do a lot of
bad things to people but are not
directly accountable through the
Democratic process
you must be
[Applause]
pleased to our recent delegation of
authority to the World Health
Organization
you know we're doing a Big Bill for
medical Freedom so everything we've done
we're making it permanent we're
expanding protections
um you know the the mandates uh Mass all
this stuff you know I'm going to talk to
the legislature about maybe including a
provision just expressly rejecting any
who involvement in the State of Florida
like we just can't do that
yeah
there's a quote limiting the size and
scope of government and bringing the
administrative state to heal requires
The Prudent use of political power
that means the Congress and Executives
get stronger
but people don't trust them
how do you
think that
well I mean look I think it's at the end
of the day some of the things that I
outlined when I gave the talk is you've
got a lot of power being exercised
across a wide range of Institutions I
think these are the power is I mean the
thing the common threat or these are all
people that are that are part of the
ruling class mentality but the idea that
you can just sit back and let that
happen without a response and right now
conservative Americans the place where
they can have their voice heard is
basically by electing people to some of
these positions you know you don't have
a lot of friends in Corporate America
you don't have very many friends in the
bureaucracy you don't have very many
friends in in higher education present
company excluded you don't have many
friends in big Tech that's just not the
way things are wired so I think it
requires us to to be smart about how
we're using power and defense of Freedom
recognizing that the threats to Freedom
are not not just about maybe a debate in
the legislative assemblies yeah that's
important you got to win those fights
but you got to be broader than that and
so fighting things like woke Capital to
me I think is something that we have to
do and so we're willing to wield
Authority against that because what
they're trying to do with things like
ESG is they're trying to take massive
concentrations of wealth and economic
power and use that to advance an
ideological agenda this is not an agenda
that could ever win at The Ballot Box
they know that so they want to kind of
do an end run around our constitutional
process and if they can get it done
through asset managers and Wall Street
Banks and all that then then they're
happy with that and I just think that
that's a danger that we've got to be
cognizant of and we got to be willing to
use Authority that we have to protect
people from having policy changed by
people who are not accountable to the
electorate
[Applause]
so what could a president do to help
with all this
well I mean
you know some of the things I think that
that so like as Governor I came in uh
and I inherited the most liberal state
supreme court in the country but it was
a 4-3 split and three of the Liberals
hit mandatory retirement so the minute I
got sworn in they were off the court so
I replaced three liberal justices with
three conservative justices so we now
have the most conservative state supreme
court in the country and that's
important because the court had really
been a roadblock to a lot of
conservative policy in Florida you look
now at the federal level uh through
Supreme Court appointments
um you know we have two justices uh
Alito and Thomas that are 100 percent uh
and then you've got I guess three others
you know that are by and large good and
then you have Roberts who is a 50 50 but
plausibly you have six votes uh that
would uphold some of the things that
that could be done so for example we
talk in the book about a lot of
conservatives that wanted the Trump
Administration to create a schedule F in
the federal service to where anybody
exercising policy judgment would be
classified as schedule F and would not
have Civil Service protections they
could be fire at will by the executive
branch that's about 50 000 people
potentially I think that's a no-brainer
to do on day one yes it will be
litigated but you know what I think we
would win that with the current court
and then there's also the question about
Article 2 means something the executive
powers and is vested in the president
nobody else and so how much can Congress
legislate a permanent bureaucracy that
undercuts Article 2 power and so a lot
of people think and I I agree that the
president can fire people to say you
just can't do anything that's admitting
defeat so I think you got to be very
aggressive about how you do that of
course all that will be contested but I
think ultimately you would be able uh to
win in court when it comes to these
issues given given the current array of
the justices that we have that will do
more to rebalance constitutional
government than anything that's been
done in a long time because right now we
have a situation where a republican wins
the White House and the left can still
controls the executive branch well that
is just unacceptable and that is not the
way the Constitution was designed
[Applause]
you make a point about uh controversy
you seem to like it uh well you actually
did say I didn't heard this before
you doubt yourself when you don't get it
the
the opportunities in controversy
they that's when people are paying
attention right
are you able to teach the treat those as
teaching moments learning moments for
everybody yeah sure I mean when there's
friction on an issue that gets elevated
and so there are times when things that
don't matter if the media tries to poke
me on sometimes I'll just ignore you
know people attacked me all the time you
know a lot of times I'll ignore because
I want to elevate the things that I want
to elevate and so you know once you have
the conflict it starts to it starts to
elevate
um part of it is Legacy Media anything
that I do immediately they are going to
react against it's just it's just their
nature at this point uh the left same
thing it's knee-jerk I mean it is what
it is but I think what we've shown is
particularly with covid when I was
getting dumped on more than any other
governor and then all the things we did
fighting Disney all this stuff a lot of
people through all of that in the
chattering class said oh he's done
politically he's not going to do well
this that they were always trying to
justify this prediction that I was just
going to fall on my base because of each
of these controversies and so obviously
the election results were very
disappointing to these people it
disabused anyone of the notion that
somehow those were negatives but I think
a lot of Republicans they they get
worried about being attacked by the
media they get worried about being
smeared it's not anything good you know
I don't read any of it so I don't really
care I mean like you know if I see New
York Times I just ignore it I mean I
just it's just I don't care
um and so it's easy for me but not
Everyone likes that but I think what we
showed in Florida is they can throw
everything they have at you and if you
just stand for what's right you don't
give them an inch and you just keep
pressing forward the people will respond
and the idea that I could go from 32 000
votes to 1.5 million votes having more
negative media attacking me than any
Governor I would say and probably modern
modern American history you know that
should show you that there are people
out there their voters they see through
all the smoke and they're just looking
for some truth in a very convoluted a
strange time and so when you're speaking
the truth I think it really connects
with people and I think that that's what
we've been able to do so don't let
fear of the media change what you're
going to do you know we just had a thing
in Florida we had a kerfuffle with the
College Board that does the advanced
placement classes for high school
because they created this class on uh
African-American studies and it was a it
was a proposed course so it hadn't been
fully vetted they wanted they wanted
feedback and three of the sections you
know we're fine was it more liberal than
I like probably but the the fourth
section was like Marx's studies I mean
it had anything you can think of in
terms of reparations it had uh queer
Theory it had intersectionality all
these things and that violated Florida
standards and so our Department of
Education rejected it now you know when
you're but we were the only state that
objected publicly not one other state in
the in the country objected publicly I
know a lot of them were objecting
privately why because you know when you
object to that what are they going to do
they're going to call you names they're
going to say all this stuff and so we've
had deal with it but you know you can't
let Media criticism prevent you from
doing the right thing and so that's what
we do we just do the right thing
you call Republicans Junior Partners in
the ruling class
explain that well I I said establishment
Republicans uh particularly people that
have been in DC a long time you know my
observation is uh you know they they
tend to want to be liked by the
corporate press uh they tend to want to
be accepted by the left and not just
elected Republicans I mean you have some
people you know who are involved in
journalism or these other things who are
purportedly right-leaning but really
crave
um I would say approval uh from from the
from kind of the left of center Elites
and I think once you do that you're
giving up the game because Legacy Media
does not want conservatives to do well
okay they're very partisan they have an
agenda you know he's left of center
journalists they don't want to give
conservatives a fair shake they have an
agenda and so uh you know you see kind
of how that is how that operates and and
that was a pretty clear dividing line
that I saw uh the ones that really cared
about kind of the DC press Corps they
tended to be the people who you know
wanted to be more ingratiated with with
kind of the the overall ruling class and
the people that were willing to really
Buck against that you know they tended
to land at more conservative policy so I
just think you got to realize kind of
you know what the name of the game is
and just be honest about uh everybody's
motivations and all this but don't think
that they're all of a sudden if you
stand for what's right they are not
going to like you that is just the
bottom line
[Applause]
why why is that why do they have that
attitude well I mean look part of it and
I talk about it in the book like when
you because I would have my constituents
would be like why are the Democrats so
much better at communicating why can't
we get on message and stuff and I don't
think that they are better communicators
I think yet if you when when you get to
DC everything is operating to advance
the left's agenda so when the Democrats
start saying you know whatever stupid
phrase they come up with next the media
amplifies that and the media projects
that and so what the average person's
getting is a very crisp whatever
catchphrase all the time when
Republicans are messaging something the
media is what they do is they try to
undercut it they try to kneecap any
policy that you put out when a
republican leaves the reservation and
opposes the party they're hailed as
Heroes by the Beltway press and people
in DC when a Democrat leaves leaves the
par a descents from the party to join
with Republicans they are pilloried they
are absolutely annihilated and so all
the incentives are kind of going in a
direction of let's get they wanted to
get more left-wing policy enacted and so
that's just the nature of kind of the
yin and the Yang of this so it is more
difficult for Republicans to communicate
not because they're not not any worse
than Democrats is because the whole
apparatus is about amplifying them and
undercutting us and that's just the way
DC works
if
so I I want to relate
journalism to college professors
and my favorite my favorite class of
person is a college professor I'm one of
them and
what are they
they
are used to being as smart as anybody
they ever met
and they and they get to explore things
for decades and they get to talk to
young people and change their lives and
be adored by them
and I think that's what it's always been
I think that's why Thomas Moore like to
teach
but I think they picked up something new
in the Progressive Era
now they get to rule
they're wise and they get to rule
now translate that into journalism
because what's their job Journal Journal
that's news the day right soup to Jore
you're supposed to write down what you
see
and that's really cool it means you get
to be a witness to great things but on
the other hand
what if you can change things
in other words isn't it true that some
of the purest things in American Life
have been taken over by the quest for
power
yeah no I think absolutely I think what
you've seen uh particularly in more
recent years uh is people going into
Legacy Media with an agenda and not that
it was ever quote fair I mean it always
had a liberal bias just because that was
the type of people who'd be drawn to it
but I think part of it's a a new
generation part of it is they use Trump
as a justification to say you know we
can't just be fair we've gotta we've got
to hold him accountable or or whatever
they they cooked up for that uh and so
now uh they're basically trying to
exercise power these are people that
could not get elected to anything
because no one would vote for them so
how do they influence policy and it's to
be a part of crafting narratives that
are going to be beneficial to their side
of the aisle so that's really what it's
become and so you know my what I my
advice in the book to to Republicans is
when you're dealing with some of those
Outlets uh you know I have press
conferences anyone can come and ask me
questions that's fine but we are not
treating those Outlets as if there's
some type of honest broker or if they're
just calling balls and Strikes because
they are not we treat them as political
actors similar to how we would treat a
democratic operative or things like that
now they don't like to be treated that
way but why would we give them the
satisfaction of acting like you know
they're some type of referee of the of
the process because they're not they're
combatants in the process and that's
fine and honestly for most of American
History the Press has been very partisan
I mean Hamilton had a paper Jefferson
had a paper that's fine and I have no
problem with them doing that but let's
just get rid of this pretense that
somehow they're serving some type of
noble public purpose at this point
because they're really not they're
trying to advance an agenda they have a
right to advance that agenda but we also
have the right as elected Republicans uh
to not give them Grist for the mill when
we don't have to to do it and so that's
just how we've handled it and people
said oh they would criticize us for not
engaging more with them you know but the
reality is I don't think very many
people trust them anymore and I can tell
you we certainly did very well in the
election even taking that posture but do
not let them use you to be able to
advance the agenda that they're looking
to do so just be smart about that and
kind of pick uh pick your spots when
you're dealing with these people
uh Thomas Jefferson paid a man named
James calendar from the Secretary of
State's office to write dirty articles
in the Philadelphia Inquirer about
Alexander Hamilton
okay one
your people are not bothering me good uh
um
concentrations of private power must
also be checked
so big Tech and Disney
they're they're their complaint is we're
private entities we have the same rights
to freedom of speech as anybody what are
you doing messing us with us with
political power how do you answer that
well Disney is a joke because in the
late 60s they were given
by the Florida legislature their own
government in Central Florida so they
basically answered to themselves the
whole thing was a fiction uh basically
you had a corporation running 40 square
miles of territory uh right in the Heart
of Florida and so that had basically
gone on and was kind of Untouchable just
because they exercised so much political
power uh over the the process they get
into this issue with the sexual
sexualization of the child programming
and getting involved in our education
bill and we just had to look at this and
say okay do they have a quote First
Amendment right to be advocating for
gender ideology in kindergarten yeah I
guess is that honestly faithful to their
fiduciary duty to their shareholders I
don't think so but that's not really uh
in my wheelhouse as Governor but what I
can tell you is under no circumstances
should the State of Florida be
subsidizing woke activism by allowing
them to have their own government so we
took it away
so they they've lost their own
government we've put the state in charge
with a control board now it's
interesting the the media
um you know tried to get spun up about
Disney trying to do these agreements you
know very quietly right before we took
control and they're acting like somehow
that they that they pulled one over on
the state uh that you'll there'll be a
lot of that comes out over the next
month or two but suffice it to say you
know the legislature is going to avoid
anything Disney did on the way out the
door but now that Disney has reopened
this issue we're not just going to avoid
the development agreement they tried to
do we're going to look at things like
taxes on the hotels we're going to look
at things like tolls on the roads we're
going to look at things like developing
some of the property that the district
owns and so at the end of the day I
think what Disney has tried to do is
they've tried to say that they should be
able to operate outside the context of
our constitutional system and Florida
now we took this action prior to the
election we won overwhelmingly
they are not superior to the people of
Florida and so come hell or high water
we're going to make sure that that
policy of Florida carries the day and so
they can keep trying to do things but
ultimately we're going to win on every
single issue involving Disney I can tell
you that
uh I went about point out two things
about that one is that last minute of
discourse was an example of the
executive temper
uh the other is Bozo is not a Disney
property
[Laughter]
okay
you're saying we're finished well yeah
at the at the risk of exceeding my
authority I know the governor wants to
get home to his family for Good Friday
tomorrow so we thank you I have one
announcement
and that is we have a complimentary copy
of his book for each of you but one per
household please we don't run out
and if you like it buy some for family
and friends keep me on that New York
Times bestseller list I can tell you
they don't like seeing my name on there
so
thank you governor
[Applause]